では 映像出します えーと
今回もこのアラハンタワッガという章の偈になります
アラハンタワッガ アラハンタっていうのは阿羅漢のことで
悟りに達した人々ということなんですね
ウィユンジャンティ サティーマントー ナニケーテエラマンティテ パンサーワパッラランティッワ オーカノーカンジャハンティテ
という 2行目の解説になります
ウィユンジャンティっていうのは
まあ一応励むことですね
興味を持つこと 励むこと
何かに興味を持って挑戦することね
頑張ること それがパーリ語でウィユンジャンティ
サティーマントーっていうのは
サティがある人々 いわゆるサティを実践する人々
修行 主語はサティーマントー
サティがある人々 実践すると言ったっても
まぁサティがある人々ですね
いわゆる経験者のことなんですね
おぬしからサティ 気づくことはできます
サティっていうのは気づくことですからね
それできる人々のことを言ってるんです
いわゆるまだまだまあやってみる人々のことじゃないんです
まぁサティができる人々は
何かに興味を持つと言えば
いわゆるサティを 気づきを持って生きることに興味はある
ナニケーテエラマンティテ
ニケータっていうのは
まぁ 住むところなんですね
根を下ろすところなんですね
だから新居 住居 住居 住むところ
ラマンティっていうのは喜びを感じる
欲しがる で ナっていうのは否定形で
テーというのは彼らは
この彼らは住居には全然喜びはないんだという風に
この意味になります それは一応表面的な意味で
また何層も分けて解説する羽目になりますけどまあ
一応まずは文字の意味を言ってるんです
なんかパーリ語って言ってればダジャレみたいなもんですね
とにかく同じ言葉に似たつづらいはあります
それでもう一度繰り返すと
サティーマントー サティがある人々は頑張っている
何かに興味を持っているということはあります
それは何かとは書いてないんですね
何に興味を持ってるかってことは
それで次は さらに彼らが家に住むところにホーム
マイホームですね そういうことはほとんど興味ないんですね
それで たとえで 2行目はたとえで終わっちゃうんですね
パンサーっていうのはこの百姓のことで
パレランっていうのは泥沼ですね
白鳥がまあ一応泥の沼に入りますけど
入って餌とか何とか食べて
これが私の住みか これが私の住むところ
これが私の縄張りということはないんですね
オーカモーカンジャハンティて
まあオーカモーカンっていうのは
まあまた意味が 2つありまして
まああちらこちらで言ってしまうという意味でも読み取れます
で まあどこへ行くかはわからない
飛ぶかはわからないんですね
とにかくせっかくもう白鳥の群れが来て
沼にずっと入ってすごい大騒ぎしているんですけど
あれは自分たちの住みかじゃないんです
それで何のことなく出て行っちゃうんですね
これはオーカアノーカンジャハンティっていう風になった方がよりしっかりしますけど
オーカンオーカンとこっちで書いて
で オーカっていうのもまた
家 家という意味になるんです
オーカンオーカンジャハンティて
家と家 家はジャハンティ捨ててしまうんだと
白鳥と同じだと  それでまとめてみると
それほどたくさんの言葉がないんですね
1つはこのサティがある人
サティが実践する人とサティがある人っていうのは結構格が違います
まあサティがある人っていうのは
まあそこサティがもうできるようになりまして
もう自分がそこをもうできるようになったっていうことにね
身についたと サティから離れなくなりましたっていうことなんですね
それでなんでニケーテ
家に喜びを感じないんでしょうかと
家って何ですか？と で
2行目も家なんですね
言葉違いますけど ニケーテっていうのも家
オーカっていうのも家なんです
住むところ 住処のことなんですね
[笑い]うん まあどうしますかね
このオウカという言葉も
ニッキータという言葉も
注釈書ではこのアーラヤという言葉に入れ替えているんですね
まあアーラヤという単語はかなり悪用されてますから
この唯識仏教ではね なんか形而上学的な意味で
生命にある 基本的にある心ですという風に言っていてね
生命にあるのは心だけだと
物質の世界は何もないんだと
物質世界は全部幻覚で
心が生み出す幻想であると
幻覚であると 幻想を作り出してはアーラヤという心がどんどんどんどんいっぱい煩悩を作って強化していきますと
それで心はずっと続けて輪廻転生になるんだということで
そんな教えをしています
アーラヤという言葉は一応仏教用語としてはありますけどね
それは大乗仏教の特権ではないんです
まあ初期仏教使ってる言葉で
唯識論ではまあ かなり悪用はしています
私のこの面白いことというのは
いつでもお釈迦様がこの「家」という言葉をいつでも使わないんだけど
使う時はあります 家って何ですかね
これちょっと私はもったいぶって厳しく言った方がいいと思いますよ
なぜかというと 私から見ればとても大事なことなんですけど
皆様聞いた 捨てた 忘れたというね
そういう調子がいいんですね
で 何十年聞いているわけ
聞いたてこれぐらい聞いてますよ
仏教はお釈迦様のおしえを知っていますか？知りませんという調子なんです
だからそれではまあ困りません
私は で 水筒が繰り返してるような感じやと
お釈迦様が言ってますからね
アングッテルニカで 大雨が降ったっても大丈夫よ
誰にも一滴もやりません
で 本当は仏教の言葉っていうのは一つでも取って
かなりなぞなぞみたいなことで
かなりそれと色々知識で遊んで覚えておかなきゃいけないんですよ
それを覚えておくと 我々の心にはいつかそれがあの機能してね
煩悩をなくすための解毒剤にはなります
それが言っちゃうとなおさら忘れてやると思うかもしれませんね
困りますと そんなことを覚えておけば
じゃあ家って何でしょうかっていえばね
まあこっちは家っていうのは英語でいうホーム
ホームという意味なんですね
ハウスじゃないんです
ハウスとホームはどちらが違いますかね
とにかく英語の専門家がいればね
ありがたいんですけど
うん ハウスとホームは違います
何が違いますかね  ハードとソフトの違い
あ？ ハードとソフトの違い
ホームスイートホーム
あ？ ホームスイートホーム
ということで シャトルできてますか？ 歯には悪いけど
あ？ 歯には悪いけど 体に悪いけれども
とても美味しいと思う
そういう遊びじゃない
[笑い]こちらは本当は真面目な話なんですけどね
あの 私は自分の管轄以外のことはもう最近やっぱり喋るのはできるだけ控えなくちゃいけないとね
何でもどんな分野のことも全部喋ったりしてね
それはすごく立場が悪いんです
私は仏教のことしか喋ってはいかんですけどね
まあハウスというのはやっぱりこの
まあハードとソフトという言葉もよくありませんだけどね
で ハウスというのは一応建物のことなんですね
我々には簡単に This is a house.と言えますよ That
house.と言えますね You
go to that house and do something.と言えますね
人にYou go to that home.とは言えないんです
それは間違いなんです
ホームというのは 1個しかないんです You
go home.と言えばはっきり意味があるんです
だから a house ですけど
a home ではないんです
a home もないし homes もないんです
まあシャーロック・ホームズはいますけど homes
という単語はないんです
ホーム 形容詞は使います In
my home. In your home. 本当は my や your とかなくてもまあ一応通じるんですね
それでまたあの home bound という言葉がありますね
普通に この まああの乗り物の場合はよく言いますね
あのＪＡＬの飛行機は
例えばニューヨークに飛んだとする
それからニューヨークから繰り返して成田に来るんですね home
bound なんですね
その場合は で 新幹線もね
3号線なんでしたら こちらの新幹線は東海道で
東海道新幹線はまあ大阪から来ると home bound なんです
ホームベースはこちらですからね
だから野球でもホームベースという言葉がありますね
ホームグラウンド  まあホームランもあるし
ホームベースだからホームベースというのはそこは狙ってますね
みんな そういうわけで
ホームということとハウスということと違って
どんな人間にも一応ホームはありますが
ハウスはない人はいくらでもいます
はい ホームレスっていう人
で はい ホームっていうのは
一応全ての生命にはあるんです
動物にもあるんです ホームレスということはあり得ません
だって誰かイカれた人が使ってる単語なんです
ホームレスやと ホームレスではないんです
ハウスレスなんです 住居がないだけ
ホームレスってわけわけじゃないんです
ただしく言えばハウスレスかレジデンスレスか何とか言わなくちゃいけないんです
ホームレスじゃないんです
あのー 試しにホームレスの人々に聞いてみていいですか
あんたどちらの人？聞いてみたらどんな答え？私はどちらの人でもありませんと言う？言わないんですよ
私は新潟ですよ 青森ですよと言うんですよ
新潟に家がある？もう家はもうないんだと
売り払っちゃったとは言うかもしれませんだけど
新潟の人なんです だからホームはあるんです
それで何がわかりますかね
物体的にハウスが ホームというハウスがある場合もあるし
ホームというハウスがない場合もあるんだけど
ホームはあるんです 仏教でこの家
家 家っていうのはホームのことなんです
一応同じ どんな言葉を使っても
まぁ一応両方のニュアンスを使ってるんです
だからこれすごく面白い単語ですよ
すごい微妙で面白いんです
あの前 後ろからどなたか顔を見えませんでしたけど
スイートホームというね
まぁちょっと品のない単語がありますけどね
しかし ホームはね 一応決まってスイートホームなんです
スイートっていうのは甘いっていう意味ではないんですから
まぁすごく喜んで飛びかかるところなんですね
いいなと思うところなんですね
例えばスイートメモリーズという言葉もあるでしょうね
やっぱりいろいろ思い出すことがありますけど
スイートメモリーズというのは
まあかなり楽しく思い出すものなんですね
忘れたくはないもの それであの人々に
どんな生き物にもホームがありますけど
そのホームはスイートでなくなっちゃうと
かなり精神的なダメージを受けたりする
ひどい目にあって生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
最近亡くなったマイケルさんにしても
なんかもう親に虐待されたあれやこれやとか
まあほとんどどうかな
作り話のように思いますけど
それで彼がなんか変な入り方をずっとしていましたと
遺言書でももうきれいさっぱり親の名前をもうカットしてしまったとかね
親に怒っていたっても
そこまで恨みは持ってるわけじゃないしね
まあ家の家族のことって誰も分かったものではないし
どうせあれぐらい子供たちを育てた父親だからね
まあそれはちょっと いい加減じゃないかなと思います
テレビであのお父さんの顔を見るって
そんなにまあ厳しいかもしれませんだけど
子供のことを大事に可愛いと思わない父親としてはね
全然見えませんし ただものすごいクールなんですね
精神不安定のだらしない息子に対してはね
おっかないかもしれません
だから精神不安定になればなるほど
父親はもっともっと冷静ですごいクール出るんですよ
まぁとにかく まぁそこのケースはどうかわかりませんだけど
もし言ってることはね
マスコミでね 本当のことだったら
万が一 マスコミは決して本当のことを報告しませんというね
まぁ対策もありますけどね
もし万が一本当のことを言ったならば
彼の人生はね すごく混乱状態になったのは
ホームはあったんだけど
スイートホームではなかったっていうことなんですね
だからホームって一体何ですかね
結局  心のよりどころですか
うん？ 心のよりどころ
うん そうなんですね 心のよりどころ
それは誰？どこどこですかとね
まぁ大体人間の場合は親なんですね
で 自分で家を作る 家族を作るまでは
やっぱり まぁ親がいるところは自分の家なんですね
そこで親がいなくなっても
親が住んでた家はもう壊れてなくなって
他の人がその土地を買ってしまっても変わらないんですね
ホームはそのままなんです
物理的にその場所が消えるとすっごく寂しいんです
自分で家族を作って子供が生まれてくると
まぁまぁそちらへんはもうホームになってしまうんですが
自分に不安がなってくると
そこがホームでなくなっちゃって
親のところがホームになるんですね
だから自分が作る家族
家っていうのは それほどしつこくホームにならないんです
嫌になったらもう別れて出ていくんだからね
子供でも放っておいて出て行く場合もあります
だからホームというのはなんかすごくもう面白い現象で
もう仮に仮の仮のホームあります
アパート借りたら じゃあ家に帰りますよってアパートに帰りますけど
そこでそこから引っ越して別なところに行ったら
家に帰らないでそちらに行くんですね
だからその場合はホームという概念だけあって
物理的にはあまり定めたことではないんですね
自分が住むところなんですね
ですから ガードの下にているホームレスにはホームがあるんです
ホームがなくなったらもう 1日も生きていられなくなるんですね
そんな簡単なことじゃないんです
大変なことなんです だから
全部まとめて結論で言えば
あの後ろで言われたように
この何て言いますか 心のよりどころ
心のよりどころなんですね
それは場所かもしれません
人かもしれません 場所も人でもなく
ただ自分の気持ちかもしれません
どちらでも過去のことですね
うーん 私は生まれた田舎にはもうほとんど行かないんです
どうしても避けられなく行かなくなっても
まあその 1時間 2時間でもさっさと帰れます
帰れます で 帰ってから自分の田舎とか平気で言うんです
この名前のアルブム村っていうのは生まれた場所ですからね
こちらでアルブム村のところの人が来たら
それは楽しくてね ああ
どうお元気ですかとかね
あれやこれやと聞いたりするんですけど
自分は行かないんですね
で なぜかというと もうホームがないんですね
もう何世代も終わったんだから
もうわけもわからない人々ばっかりですね
人々も全然顔もわからない
家も環境ももうむちゃくちゃ変わってるんだからね
まあ変わってないと言えば道路だけですね
それでもいろいろあちこち新しい道路できたりしているし
だから自分の生まれた田舎はどこにあるのかと
やっぱりただ心の気持ちだけになっているんですね
私は自分の田舎のことをすごく喜んで説明するところで
誰かの日本の方がではせっかくスリランカに行くんだから
このスイートホームのところに連れて行ってないんですけど
あなた嘘を言ったんじゃないかということになるかもしれません
だから もっとわかりやすく言うと
我々我々は何かに愛着を入れて
そこをよりどころにして生きているんです
だから私の場合はもう 60年ぐらい前のある場所とある人々もみんな亡くなってますけど
そのグループで その仲間ですかね
その場所とその当時にいたそのおばあさんとかね
まあおばあさん何人かとかね
まあおじいさんたちもいましたけど
自分の家族ともそのグループみんな死んでますけどね
一人もいない その子供の子供世代になっていて
その連中も結婚しているし
もうさっぱりもう関係もない
わかりもしないというね
なのに自分がどこに愛着をつけているかというと
あのもうかつてあったなんとかの環境下ですね
夢で田舎を見たっても
現在あるものは見えませんね
そういうことなんですね
ホームというのは それで生命にはホームというものがなく生きてはいられないんです
[咳]動物の中でもね
当然自分の住処っていうものはね
作りますよ その環境から外へ出すとかなり厳しいんです
我々は鳥籠で鳥を飼って
いろいろ言葉を覚えさせたりとか
いろいろやってますけど
鳥の方はそこじゃないんです
三世代  四世代  五世代まで人間が育てて
もうそこで卵を産んで
そこでもうそういう あれはもしかすると人間の家が
もう人間が自分のホームやと思う可能性はありますけどね
大体今は犬猫にひどいことを精神的なことをなってるでしょう
だから野生はホームじゃなくなってるんですね
家がホームになっちゃって
インドだけいますね あの
一度も飼ったことがない犬たちが
いわゆる野生の犬たちが
世界で もしかするとインドだけかもしれません
で 犬の研究をする場合は
もともと犬はどんな風に生活していたのかというと
やっぱりインドに行く羽目になります
じゃあその犬たちはどこにいるのかというと
村にいるんです 野生には行かないし
インドではあれほど巨大インドですけど
野生っていうのはないんです
木は１本もないんだからね
全部壊してるんです 森はないんです
面白いんです 自分の国に着陸すると
どこに着陸するって藪じゃないかと怖くなるほど
もういっぱい全面的に植物なんです
かなり近寄ってくると
あ ちょっと空いてる場所がある
それでもココナッツの木の上からすっと下げて着陸しなくちゃいけないんです
ちょっと上に上がったら
もう滑走路じゃなくても緑しか見えませんしね
で それももうかなりスピードで変わってはいきますけどね
それで比較すると インドって何なのかとね
木はない だからもう犬たちがね
野生に戻りたいって言ったって
野生はもう森がないんですけど
しかし 誰も飼ってないんですが
犬たちは人間がいるところでうろうろうろうろうろうろ生活しているんですね
人間捨てたものがあったらそれも食べるし
自分で何か何かもうあっちこっちで餌を探して食べてるし
人間のことは全然気にもしないし
攻撃もしないし インド人にあんまり動物飼わないんですね
水分ケチですからね で
牛以外は飼わないんですね
牛は飼っているか拝んでいるかどちらかわかりませんしね
だからこの だから結局は人間飼うことに愛情がある人々は
じゃあ飼ってみようかなと
犬たちもああ良かったということで
それでもホームになってしまったんでしょうしね
で 猫もそうでしょうし
しかし猫はおそらく強引に飼ったでしょうね
猫は未だにもう自分の野生のセクションは絶対忘れ
大事に守っているんです
だからプライド高いんですね
だからそこがもしかするとホームかもしれませんしね
私はもう考えているのは
この渡り鳥とかの場合はホームはどこですか
年中ずっとひと回りしていますからね
だから渡り鳥にはあの
自分のホームベースという国っていうのはないでしょうね
シベリアからこちらに来る鳥たちはね
まぁただ向こうはものすごい冬になってくるともう生活できないんだから
まぁ雪が少ないところに来て
それで子供を育てて大きくなったら
じゃあ帰りましょうということで向こうに行って
また餌を取って食べていて
あぁまぁそろそろもうこちらでは生活できなくなりますから
では出かけましょうということで出かけるしね
だからずっと旅をしていますけど
やっぱりホームというのはそのルートなんですね
そういう動物たちには
それでヒマラヤももう頑張って上から飛び飛ぶグループがいますからね
あれまで上に上がるのはね
できないんですよ でも飛ぶ
で あの気流とか何とかすごく計算して計算して
まぁまずこうやって着陸して待っていて飛んでみるんですね
飛んでみたら あ 今日は調子がいいなとわかったら
もう飛んで それで気流に乗ってどんどん上に上がって
適当な高度になったらもう上がって
そういうあらゆる工夫をして
まぁとにかく目的を作ってそこに行く
それからそこから別のところ
目的を作ってそこに行く
そういうことで たとえ渡り鳥であっても
ホームというのはあるんです
そこは一時的にでも曖昧になると
ものすごく混乱するんです
その親が死ぬとね みんなすごく悲しくなる
親のことを心配している
ないと思いますよ 自分のホームが壊れていくんですよ
一人の親が死ぬと もう半分壊れたんだから
彼結構すごいショックなんです
戻るところはなくなったと
もう一人の親が亡くなったら
もうまだものすごいショックで戻るところがなくなったと
別に物理的に戻るわけじゃないんですけど
だから愛着を付けるところ
何かホームベースがあって
我々は生きることに挑戦しているんですね
そうでないと この生きるということをやりきれないんですね
いくらやってもやってもやりきれない
締め切りがない もう締め切りがないんでしょうかね
終わりがないんですね
すごく心には負担になるんです
だから家がホームがあったら
こちらで東京ででも会社で仕事はできます
なくなったらもう追いつかないというか
もうなかなか落ち着かないんですね
うん 次 このホームっていうものはですから
あるべきですか べきっていうことではなくて
これはあります まず ホームがあるんだから
生きることの苦しみにやりきれない
終わりがない 人生 そこに気づかないで生きることはできます
たくさん仕事あるんだと感じると
どうしてもすっごくストレスになるんです
大量な仕事は もう生きていられなくなります
だから人間はいろいろいろいろプログラム組んだり
締め切りを作ったり いろんなことを作ったりして
なんとかけじめを作ったりして
もうなんとかやってるんですけどね
恐ろしいストレスになって破壊になるぐらいのもう苦しみがあるんですよ
そこであのホームという観念があると
こんなまあもう墨染ほどのやらなくちゃあかんあったってても
まあ全部放り投げて家に帰りますよという気分でいるんです
時々仕事をクビになったり辞めさせたりする人々はこちらでね
まあこういうことになりましたと私ども言いますけどね
それでそれでお母さんに言ったら家に戻りなさいというんですけど
もう家には戻りたくないということでね
すごく苦しんでるんですね
私は何人かに言ったんで
まあだから戻るしかないでしょうと
でもお金も終わってるし
アパートももう返さなくちゃいけないし
それであんた何するのかと
家に戻るしかないです
それ家に帰りたくないって人々はやっぱり家出して生きているんですね
だから何か何かホームは対でなくなったんですね
だからその恨みで家出してこちらで頑張って
こちらでうまくいかないとまた戻らなくちゃいけないんだから
すごくプライドでへこむんですね
しかし そこまで家を敵に回して頑張ってやっても
結局寄るところはその家なんですね
はい まあ大体人間そこまででも家の家という概念に現象については考えてないんですね
これ考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
我々はなにをよりどころにしているのかと
で 考えてみると もう大したことはないんでしょうしね
まあまあ ボロ家があるかもしれませんし
もうバスに乗っても電車に行って
それから時間 時間 朝と昼夜と日本しかないバスもあれば
それに乗って また降りて
また歩いて行かなくいかないところかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそういうところでも自分の家っていうことになるんです
そういうつまらないところでも家になってしまうんですからね
それ考えた方がいいんですよ
そこで じゃあ我々具体的に家っていう概念が我々を助けてくれるのかと
支えているのかと ということですね
助けてくれないとは思いますけどね
お釈迦様がその程度ではなくて
もっともっと人間には考えられない別なことを考えているんですね
この家という概念がね
人間を生かしているんですね
苦しみを忘れさせているんですね
精神的にクタクタ疲れてるんだけど
崩壊させないで ものすごく苦しませるんですね
いわゆる人を一旦殺したらそれで終わりだから
殺すだけはしないで どこまででもいじめていると
痛めつけて 死んだら痛めつけませんだから
死ぬギリギリまで痛めつけて
まだちょっと手抜きで
まだ痛めつけているという風な生き方なんですね
生きるということは なのに
いくら苦しみがあっても
このホームという愛着があって実体はないんです
心にある微妙な気持ちだけなんですね
その愛着があって それが支えよりどころにして
苦労は気にしないことにするんです
気づかないことにする
見ないことにする この気づきで気づきの実践
瞬間瞬間の現象を気づいてみると
その人にはよりどころは存在しないと見えてくるんです
最初はよりどころがないと聞いてものすごくショックなんです
修行者でも よりどころはありえないと
これただの気持ちだけでしょうと
なんだこれはと 物体があると思ったとこ
これないんだからね それ
で そこで初めて命は見えてくるんですね
やっぱり命っていうのはそういうないこと
ないものをよりどころにして生きてきたんだと
それが生き方だと ああ
これもうよりどころがなくなった
で そこをそれでも観察していくと
次のステップで心は解脱になるんですね
で あれ並のショックじゃないんですよ
本当にもうよりどころがないっていうことははっきりと気づけて
ものすごい優れた知恵で見えていくとね
ちょっと親が死んだぐらいの程度のものじゃないんです
親が死んだって家があるんだとかね
兄弟が仲が良ければ 両親も死んだったら上の兄弟がよりどころになってしまったりするし
そんないい加減なところではもうないんですね
そんな時のショックとは結構違います
かなり厳しいんですけど
本当にないということはわかっているとね
それで家がよりどころにしているならば悟ってないんです
輪廻転生しているんです
悟ったっていうことは
よりどころがなくなったんです
あの幻覚現象が消えちゃったんです
どこもよりどころないんですから
何のことも言えなくなります
それでまたあの元のたとえは
渡り鳥の家はどこにあるのかと聞いた状態と同じくなっちゃうんです
あの日本で日本の大変大事な鳥として見ている
あのなんとかするがいるでしょ
かんちょう？え？タンチョウする
まあ日本の芸術では まああちら描いてこちら描いて
もうえらく喜んだりして
結局は日本の鳥じゃないんです
ただの渡り鳥なんです
だから天下好きな人間だから
なんでそれには国際的な問題を作らないんですかね
タンチョウするは日本の独特の鳥であると
ソ連はなんとも言ってはあかんと
何か国際問題でも作った方がいいのに
口で書いてるあらゆる様々な絵とか何とか持っていって
ほらこれ日本の文化でしょうにとかね
だからタンチョウするがソ連のものか日本のものか
ちょっとわかって 総裁もわかってないでしょうに
ですから タンチョウするの
まあその場合は英語の単語でドメスティックなんですからね
どこですかと よくわからないんですね
だからホームがない人は誰にも何ものかっていうとさっぱりわからなくなるんです
しかし その人にとっては生きる苦しみはなくなっているんです
だからこの悟りということが
この 何て言いますかね
誤解とかなんとかならない
しっかりした心の経験なんですね
このしっかりした その経験するためには
報恩というものはしっかりとはっきりとしなくちゃダメなんです
自分が何をよりどころに生きているのか
それを探して探してみるとなくなってしまうんですね
そんなのは あると思っていたのに
あると思っていたことがないとわかったらすごいショックなんです
だからお釈迦様がこの白鳥
白鳥ですかね スワンは黒い鳥見ますけどね
あの鳥なんて言いますかね
白鳥では白いって意味でしょう
スワンは英語で日本語でどうなるんですかね
何か名前ないですか？とにかく白いもあるし黒いもある
いるんですけどね だからとにかくそれは当たり前ですからね
インドにもいるし だからお釈迦様がそこを見たらね
白鳥たちがいっぱい来ていて
沼は我が物のようにあっちこち上がったりして大騒ぎして
もう日本に来た時でもね
大騒ぎですからね あとで跡形もなく消えていくんです
そこで この阿羅漢に達した人の生き方を表現しようかなと
阿羅漢の方々はどこかの村に行ったら村は大騒ぎになります
で 村人の存在はもうほとんど小さくなってしまって
聖者のグループの存在だけすごい派手になって
みんな大騒ぎして説法を聞いたり
お布施をしたり 随分仲良くしたりはするんです
悩み事を言ったり 昔の話ですからね
仕事終わったら そういうお坊さんたちが修行するところにみんな行って
なんか家に行くような感じで
じゃあ行きましょうという感じで
それで後で跡形もなく消えていくんです
出ていくときは何のこともなく
何の躊躇もなく 誰にも断ることなく消えるんです
だからその住んでいるところに行ってみたら
もうない いない 一般信者さんにとっては結構ショックですけどね
なくなりました いなくなったと
またそのうちどこかで来るでしょうと思うしかないんです
だからこのホームレスという言葉は
阿羅漢に覚った人に使うべき言葉なんです
だらしないこの負け犬たちに使う単語じゃないんです
ただのアドレスレスだけですよね
欲はありありですからね
その人々もやっぱり報恩ということがあるんだから
公園で冬でも頑張れるんですよ
すごく雨が降ったりしてね
もう冬の時でも雨が降ったりするでしょうに
それで傘も4本ぐらいね
あちこちつけて 体その中で隠して
何か毛布はいっぱいこのひどい匂いも出す毛布で体をもう巻いて巻いてくくまっているんですよね
なんでそこまで頑張って生きるんですかね
どこで心の中にあるんですよ
支えてくれる何かの気持ちが
それはかえってそういう人々の場合は強烈なんです
何でもうまくいっている人と違って
だから何でもうまく行く人はもう修行の場合でもものすごく早く成功に達するんです
うまくいかないと もう愛着っていうのはどんどん強烈になってくる
だから申し訳ないんですけど
日本の宗教に対する日本人のアプローチっていうのは
もうこれはもう負け犬たちの世界という
もう失敗したらお寺にすがるというね
どこかの道場に行って
3ヶ月間ぐらいもういい加減な生活をして
またのこのこと社会に戻ると
そんなところじゃないんですけどね
それはまあ キリスト教の世界なんですね
そちらの責任あるんですよ
社会で何もできなくて
何やっても負けちゃって
ひどい目に遭ったりすると面倒見る義務があるんです
教会にも あと全部全知全能のもう完全たる慈しみのある
人のことをものすごく愛する神に作ったもんだからね
神は父親だから あの連中も
だから神がアホなことをやっちゃうと
それは親のあれね うちは何とか庇ってあげないと神を大事に信仰することになりませんよ
私はちょっと失敗したことぐらいてめえらにできないのかと神が怒るんだからね
面倒ぐらい見てやれと
だから彼らがこんな障害を持ってる人やら失敗した人々やら
まあ私は負け犬という失礼な単語を使いますけど
そういう人々をね 言うでしょう
それは神様が何かが とりあえず自分のことなんですけど
まあとにかくまあ 宗教っていうのはそういう世界ではないんです
だから勝利者の道なんですよ
勝利を得たいという もうやりきれないほど仕事ある人生を
とにかくこの締め切りまでにやって終わりたいというね
いう気持ちある人には
まあ仏教はふさわしくなるんですね
そういうことで あの そういう法門というのは麻薬みたいなもんでしょうね
で まあ病院に行っても
まあいろいろことを体にする場合は
まあ麻酔やらいろいろものを入れたりして
まあ何のこともないようでひどい目に遭わせるんですね
しかし 麻薬そのものが体に悪いんですけどね
だからこの私たちは生きる苦しみをなくすために使う麻薬ですね
法というのにニケータというのはオウカというのは
それが悟った人にはないと
あってなくなるわけじゃないんです
我々はあると思っている
麻薬ですからね だから麻薬の力で苦しみは感じないだけで
苦しみが消えたわけじゃなくて
麻薬は大変幸福をもたらすわけじゃないんです
ただ 鈍くした 知らないことにしてあげただけ
あるにも気づかないようにしてくれるだけ
体医者がもう切ってるのに気づかないようにしてあげてるあげてるだけ
気づけなきゃいいっていうことですかね
だからそれは知らなかったらいいでしょうという話でしょう
自分がひどい病気になって
知らなかったら大丈夫だよと
大丈夫じゃないんですけどね
本人に言わないでくれと
これはひどい病気だと
本人に言わないでおけば
本人それで治りますかね
彼は 1000万人に一人にもかからない病気だと
治療法は何もないんだと
これにかかったらもう二
三年で人生終わりだと
だから本人に言わないことにしましょう
という生き方ですね だから法に頼ることも同じことなんですよ
法という概念が知らないことにしてあげましょうということなんです
で 生きることっていうのは苦しくて
だから観察していくと
それはただの幻想で観念で
観念であるとわかるし
それから失敗すればするほど
その現象 その観念がかなり強力になる
だから失敗したら悟りの可能性も消えちゃいますよ
[音楽]